[Music]
hey there i'm george campbell co-host of
the ramsey show and we're back with
another edition of the best of the
ramsay show
this episode features unbelievable
disputes between spouses financial abuse
infidelity hiding purchases and
addiction it gets real and we hear it
all check this out heidi is with us in
atlanta hey heidi welcome to the ramsay
show
thank you for having me and talking to
me today how are you
sure what's up
um i'm in a little bit of a predicament
um i'm coming to the realization that
to possibly make some
decisions that are not only financial
i'm having trouble understanding you can
you speak directly into your phone
please
sounds muffled hey
are you
can you hear me now yes ma'am a little
better go ahead and try again
tuck bolt
um yeah it's just you and me and dave
like 10 million other people it's good
yeah exactly
um i can't speak too loudly because my
husband's downstairs and i don't want to
be interrupted by him
um
so
i'm in a situation where
my husband's not wanting to work on our
finances together
this last two and a half years he has
not been contributing towards our
joint account at all
money is completely separated and uh
recently he informed me that
um if i want my financial situation to
change i have to do something
about it
um because i've suggested to him i've
been listening to you for the last
month or so here and talking about how
if we're gonna get out of that we need
to work on it together
um i've sent him
different shows that you've um released
and in order for him to listen to it
he's just not on board with it
um why i had
i'm sorry why does he not want to
combine your finances
um
he says that he's got a plan in place
that works for him and um it does not
include you
yeah so how long has he been having an
affair yeah
um
our finances basically have been always
separated
that one
i
i don't know of any
particular situation where
he is having enough here
are you safe
um yeah
in my home i'm i'm okay i just
can't speak loudly okay
you can't what can't speak loudly
um so
you just called two guys
listening to how you are having to speak
in your own home
out of fear of a man
who calls himself your
husband and i need you to hear from me
who's also a husband sitting next to
another guy who's a husband
that safety can come in the form of
physical safety and it can also come in
the form of psychological safety where
you don't feel welcome in your own house
and dave's question about
is he having an affair i need you to
hear
hear the behavior
hear what your husband's trying to tell
you through his behavior
that is you are not a priority his
priorities are somewhere else
and he is disinterested in
a relationship with you
correct
right
and that's heartbreaking and i'm saying
it real direct and i know that's hard um
but you are not safe
at all you know that right i'm not
telling you that you don't know you know
that right
yes i know that and this is part of
the last four months has been very
leveling
there you go and so dave's question
about an affair that that was to be my
first question too something has changed
in this marriage it was already separate
and we already would have poked at you
for having different accounts
something else has changed either he's
about to leave or he already has left
or something has shifted or he's in
trouble he's got an addiction issue
something else has shifted he's in love
with something else
right
um
his phone
um politics
um there's a lot of
different things that are distracting
him but we are all in the same house
together we ever since covered including
the kids
how many children do you have
two girls and what is your income
well
right now it's not where it could be um
it's about 40 000.
what could it be
if i went back to my former career that
i left to try to do this rv life with
him
um i could be making upwards of 90
on my own
so maybe what she could be making
upwards of 90 on her 90. i didn't hear
the 90. okay i'm sorry and um how old
are your children
13
okay
can i ask you a real hard question
yes
is this the picture
of
love that you want to communicate to
them
no it's not and that's i mean i've been
you know wrestling with this like i said
for the last four months and
after speaking to some of my friends and
coming to the realization that
you know not only is it financial abuse
it's my mental health it's my children's
mental health
it's all of it it's this is not the
person my parents raised
um
my dad i was completely i bought this
house on my own single
um i was completely debt free when i got
married
and that has changed okay and i want to
get back to who i was before yeah so
here's what you're gonna have to do
um your friends aren't who walk through
you with this except as friends but you
need to get a good counselor yes so you
need to go see a marriage counselor
starting today
that is a strong person that will try to
help you save your marriage if it's
salvageable
that will give you some verbage and some
positions to remind you you're not crazy
because you got two guys here saying
you're not crazy
okay and we're both we both know this
stuff okay so um you need to get a
counselor that can guide you through
this you don't want to do this off of a
radio call and you don't want to do this
off of your friend's opinion over a
glass of wine you need to get a
counselor in your corner they can give
you some ways to explain to your husband
that what will amount to ultimately an
ultimatum a boundary a boundary that
says you are going to re-engage
or you're going to disengage we're not
going to play here in the middle
and i'm not going gonna be abused at
this level anymore
and you gotta have someone help you set
that boundary not two guys on the radio
but you're not crazy and you need to do
this and you need to do this right now
john we gotta go back to that last
caller for a second uh because there's a
whole lot of that
in america today yeah okay there's a lot
of different ways that husbands and
wives
interact
over money
there's a situation where they work
together and everything's combined and
they make decisions together and when
they make decisions on their spending
and they're investing they realize that
they are truly adding a level of unity a
level of oneness to their relationship
level of communication their
relationship and that's plan a
and it has the highest probability of
increasing the quality of your marriage
and in the highest probability of you
becoming wealthy plan a does
plan b
is to healthy mentally mature
emotionally mature people who operate
financially like roommates
but both of them have a vote and there
is a mutual respect and there's
communication between them but they run
separate accounts that's a plan b
there's a that lowers the probability of
wealth building and the quality of the
marriage substantially
but it still functions
plan c that's even worse
is
mom or dad husband or wife one of the
two is in charge
and the other one is doled out money
as an allowance well i gotta check with
mama see if i gain money
uh meaning the wife is in charge of the
money or i gotta ask my husband because
he handles all the money
and uh or you know we don't i don't know
if we i don't know what we've got and
they die the one that handles the money
dies and the other one just left
clueless
and with no skills because they don't
have decades of handling anything they
basically are a glorified child being
taken care of by an unglorified parent
in that setting and that is damaging to
the relationship and it's really
damaging to the money really damaging
the money
that
plan f where you fail the test
is one toxic member
of the team
is in control of the money and the other
person it's finance that's abuse with
toxic financial abuse right
the extreme of that
is there's a high correlation
in the data and in the actual practice
and i've seen it on the financial side
i've talked with other coaches you and i
have talked about this
uh you probably can cite a study i've
just talked to other people that have
seen it in practice that if if a husband
has extreme control
over the finances
to the point that the wife is not
allowed to make any can't go to the
grocery store by herself can't pay any
electric bill she's given two dollars at
a time
not two thousand dollars at a time
uh extreme control
probably 90 to 95 percent of the time
he's hitting her
domestic violence tied to that if
there's that level of control you can
just about count on it that last one
gets really close to that that's why my
first question was are you safe right
because yeah i feel it she wanted to say
safe was emotional abuse but she's
upstairs and can't speak loudly because
he's downstairs that's right which makes
me wonder about that whole thing and how
many calls have we taken you and i have
taken that have a couple on they
disagree they're either laughing about
it or they're ingest but serious
that's the first one of these where
somebody's hiding upstairs saying
uh help
it's
not yeah it's not the first one sadly
but it won't be the last one but the the
point of us bringing this up is um i
mean to outline what a plan is b plan is
c plan is and f plan is um here's the
thing
every one of those regardless of who you
are and which player you are in that
role is a choice to go forward that way
right
and i would encourage every one of you
to choose to move towards the a plan
yeah
um or if you are unsafe to choose to get
out yeah
uh whether you're unsafe emotionally or
you're unsafe physically i don't i don't
tell people to file divorce and i'll
tell people file bankruptcy but there
are situations where you're unsafe you
need to get out there and if you find
yourself she mentioned something at the
end of that call that
just buried itself in my heart a little
bit she said
this isn't who i am
i've looked up i bought this house i
bought on my own i had a great career i
was debt-free
and now i'm somebody else that's common
language of somebody who's in an abusive
relationship
i have become somebody else
in order to keep myself safe keep my
kids cave keep this guy from don't keep
his rage keep his rage down that's right
that's right and when you look in the
mirror and say who are you who have you
become because there's a rage person in
your life that is signal number one call
somebody and get some help right away
yep yeah
absolutely yeah that's um
the the wrathful man
proverbs talks about is a dangerous
character gal amen it's a dangerous
character and um
uh and the sad thing is is that he's
probably has very little coping skills
himself and that's what drives him to
rage that's right yeah
and he's get some i'd love for him to
get some help as well and she mentioned
something
the number of calls i'm taking dave on
my show the number the data is bearing
it out the folks over the last 24 months
who have gotten
psychotic about their cell phones and
new data and new information and news uh
it's destroying people put your phones
down and say i got a problem and go
re-engage or call it get a human being
get a counselor yes you do not need your
put your turn your stupid screen off and
get around human beings
i mean it's uh screen time
uh people have gone down the conspiracy
theory or
alternate theory or whatever you want to
call it uh rabbit hole and they live
there they live they've moved in yeah
and so i've had to put up a boundary in
my life i've got a certain number of
acquaintances slash friends that i'm
like
not here yeah i'm not i'm not talking
about cove anymore i'm tired of it there
you go it's not it's no longer fun i
don't talk about anymore yeah because
you're all stupid all of yours
i'm just not talking about anymore you
know
and uh if i die from it y'all just y'all
make fun of me then that's fine but it's
all good and you can be mad at dave
ramsey and you're already mad at him so
screw it you know whatever it's okay so
um but i mean this whole thing you've
gotta
this rage that has welled up inside of
the started with a quarantine
and has driven people the fear off of
that it's an existential crisis of
another kind it is and we are feeling a
mass
psychosis man we've got
dude and this is how nonsense gets
started dave that you can't wheel back
and so i want people to put their phones
down and go call a friend call and ask
your close buddies have i've been raged
out and if they're good friends they'll
be honest with you say no or they'll
look you out and say yeah we're worried
about you yeah i've had those moments in
my life man well you get in fight mode
and you stay jacked up and you never get
off you just go looking for the next
fight the next fight the next fight yeah
and it's a jacked up thing and then all
you do is just keep fox news on or cnn
on whichever version you are and they'll
feed it to you and they'll make sure
you're pissed off all 24 7. that's how
they get paid exactly and uh and if not
you can turn on your local news and a
tornado's gonna kill you but yeah
oh my god
there's a snowstorm
it's like oh geez
get in the truck and drive to work
or don't but pick one don't be inc go be
don't but don't don't
turn the knuckle about it turn the tv
off turn it off it's white powder it's
going to be okay
all right and so um
yeah and but the the wussification
of america this idea that we don't know
how to fight through something and then
when we get into this
we don't have the the we don't have the
character structure to fight like a man
instead we fight like a boy
and your power and control jacked up
bully mode
instead of
manly
righteous anger at something that's
truly principled and wrong
and so you become an activist god help
you because you don't have anything else
to do
you know it's just it's weird it's weird
it's happening out there and so if
you're in those situations folks get get
some help call somebody please call
somebody get somebody in your corner
walk you walk you out of it and put the
phone down
this is the ramsey show
david is with us david is in louisville
kentucky hi david how are you
i'm doing well and thanks for taking my
call dave and george i appreciate your
guys's wisdom and opinion so i'll try to
be brief and um
uh a little groundwork i'm an
over-the-road truck driver uh i am out
five days at a time and i have rotating
weekends my wife works full-time uh i
would say two full-time jobs she also
takes care of our kids all week while
i'm gone um so we have a 20 month old
and we have a second baby boy coming in
nine days wow
so yeah mama's got her hands full um i
try to help while i'm there and this job
does have predictable schedules uh which
really helped a lot but here's what
happened
a lot of relational stuff and and a
little financial thing but i i do wonder
your thoughts on the financial thing so
when we put the second car seat in the
uh she had a small suv
i was the one who said you know this
thing's a little tighter than it needs
to be in here for you having to pack
them out in and out all day by yourself
we might look at some other options
so we talked about it could not agree on
makes models anything i'm looking at
minivans she's looking at suvs um we
actually went and physically looked at
some cars just to get some ideas
try to compromise on things
and there was a little compromise on
cars you know different makes and models
and then we were trying to figure out
what would be realistic in our range
with the trade and all that and uh
there were several we both got a little
uh sticker uh eyeballs there and then
tried to back away from that
um and there were several talks about
you know we're not going to finance
anything different than where we are now
to get into the vehicle we need to be
you know a lateral move is fine but
we're not going to go backwards
um
next thing i know saturday she sends me
pictures of this van that she just went
and picked up
and uh financed 10 grand
we owed five as it was on the corner and
we had the money to pay it off we were
doing the store mode thing
[Music]
and i don't know
i don't know if she just
had a change of heart we had a
commitment conversation last night and
we agreed there's a lot of individual
and relational counseling needed to
figure out how we even got to where we
thought this was a good idea
my thought on the financial side is we
turn right back around and sell that van
and whatever the gap money is
between the sale and paying off the loan
that's what we go by um
she seems to still think i don't know at
what level that this was a good idea and
that we should keep it
that it's just five grand further
backwards
and that we can we can pay it off if we
buckle down so i'm curious what your
thought is there
wow
um
well i'm vacillating between this lady
is completely overwhelmed with two
little
babies she's pregnant
and and the fact that she completely
lost her dadgum mind
and went again and and went against
everything in the relationship lied to
her husband and acted like she wasn't
even married
um so i mean part of me simply
sympathetic to where she is and how
overwhelmed she is and i get all of that
but part of me is really ticked at her
right now
and i suppose and i suppose you're
probably 10x of both of those
exactly and and i do understand on the
one hand
and
not necessarily even my bigger vehicle
is the right choice of vehicle the loan
is completely separate from that
well in the dis but this decision making
process that is completely out of
control
you're not going to ever have anything
financially
until we solve whatever is broken there
in her
uh in her mind on how relationships work
um so
i um
uh uh
yeah
financially what you need to do sell the
car
and you need to get a car that you can
afford
um and also that would probably be a
good idea for her to
do to recommit to your marriage not
necessarily to the ramsey steps or
something you guys may decide together
that you want to go deeply in debt if
you want to do that that's fine but
whatever the first thing that has to
happen is you all have to get on the
same page and agree to keep your word to
each other
you just can't have a relationship where
you just
don't keep your word to each other or
where you act independently unilaterally
of each other like this
there's there's just no data that says
that creates a quality relationship
yeah the financial piece can be undone
today but the
relational piece the trust that's going
to take a while to build back up and i
think you're right that counseling is in
order and on the financial side do you
guys still have other types of debt
outside of this car loan yeah
how much how much a little bit yeah
they're working we're working baby step
two we're close we had yeah we had five
grand left on the cars this current car
is now ten so an additional five or six
um she has a
17 000 student loan which would have
been the next thing we tackled and then
some petty collections that she has from
old credit cards yeah
uh my guess is my guess is your wife
feels like that she's been running her
life by herself already
for a long time because you're just
never there
and um she feels abandoned and she just
had to do what she had to do as an
abandoned single mom i'm thinking that's
where she is emotionally
you don't feel like that's where she is
but i think that's where she thinks she
is
i agree with that that that that's
probably pretty fair for how she feels
emotionally i guess my
concern is that you know and i don't
downplay that at all but
at least relationally and financially
we've agreed to be on the same page and
then you went and did yeah i mean i i i
i'm i'm livid of her breaking her word
and and just doing this but i'm trying
to figure out what level of distress she
must have been in to do that because it
sounds like you all had very clear
conversations and then she just went and
did whatever the flip she wanted to do
anyway so which just tells me she's just
in freak out mode
i guess i mean because i i don't this
lady does not sound like someone who is
obstinate arrogant
she doesn't sound like that person to me
she sounds more like somebody who feels
i think she's a cornered animal and she
bit you
you know what i'm saying
yeah that's how it feels so you got to
get to the bottom of that before you can
fix this van thing the van problem is
that is the symptom it's not the thing
so
and it may be dude you're coming off the
road and you got little babies
and she she's overwhelmed
and you may be coming off the road and
doing something else so that you can be
there for your family for a season
i don't know
but i do know you need to sit down the
marriage counselor for sure i'm not
qualified to unravel all this i can just
i can kind of get on her side for a
minute but there's no way to justify
what she did on the other hand so i can
get on your side and be pissed about it
too i get it i understand where your
head is but i'm trying to figure out
what caused this so it doesn't happen
again
that's the thing because if you don't
break this you're going to be broke your
whole life
so a couple days ago george and i took a
call from an over-the-road truck driver
who's uh he had been talking with his
wife about trading cars
and uh without talking to him she went
and traded cars and went further into
debt he was pretty irate about that
um because they didn't we're not in
agreement about that and she just went
and did whatever she wanted to do
and we talked to him for a few minutes
the more we talked to him the more if
you go back and listen to the call
uh the more we were questioning what's
really going on because he was like he
set her up threw under the bus pretty
much and then we're like yeah i think
you probably you're over the road she's
pregnant she's got a baby doing nine
days
and
you probably there's something else
going on here you read between the lines
i actually said you may need to come off
the road and take care of your family
and you guys need to get in marriage
counseling so um she apparently was
listening uh or went back and listened
to the call uh and disagreed with a
whole bunch of her
uh the things her husband said about her
uh and the conclusions we came to about
her as a result uh and so forth so send
us a long email
uh and and so we thought it'd be fun to
kind of go back through that because
it's really interesting so here's the
deal um well let's just say okay i
listened yesterday got to hear the call
you took from my husband regarding the
purchase of a van resulted in financing
10k i know responding probably won't get
air time to resolve the plethora of
issues you two seem to pick up on but i
felt at least i could provide some
context for my actions that would
hopefully lead to a rebranding of my
sanity because i said she may have lost
her dadgum mine
and accountability for the situation the
truth is partially as you put it i was
backed into a corner and i bit back
so it sounded like they couldn't come
into agreement and he's on the road left
her you know stranded with a bunch of
kids and she just did whatever she
wanted to do kind of thing that's what's
my point and so
um
then she goes on for about
a page and a half explaining why it's
okay to borrow money to buy a van and
all this stuff which of course is not
true
uh my husband didn't mention that he's
packed all of his things and moved out
that's true he did not mention that and
has taken half of our emergency fund
with him
about nine days before i deliver our
second child oh really that's just nice
no he didn't mention that because i
probably would have ripped him a new one
for doing that it's like if you're gonna
leave you don't leave nine days before
baby comes dube
uh you know this didn't just suddenly
happen so yeah we would have um george
and i would have teed off on him on that
me more than george but because george
is generally nice
uh she closes with i'm not stupid i've
not lost my mind but backed into a
corner with no other resources or
choices i think i can own this one and
that's after rationalizing again for
five paragraphs that buying the van was
a good idea so let's go back and
re-regroup on this whole thing for a
little bit um number
one i don't like it
when any of you
none of us at ramsay like it when you
take our good common sense advice that
is meant for you to prosper in your
family and you weaponize it to use it on
your family or weaponize it to use it on
your spouse there's a thing in here
where he says
she says
he he refused any car i looked at
because he and he said dave always says
if the answer is no we don't do anything
if the answer if we can't come into
agreement the answer is no well that's a
general principle yes but what's going
on here is
you two are a hot mess
that's what's really going on here
both of you jessica you with your
rationalization
which i completely understand how you
get there in the middle of him being a
control freak and you getting ready to
have a baby and i get all of that but
you rationalized your butt off girl i
mean it's ridiculous and and him with
his lying to us and weaponizing
advice that we give here and using it to
verbally thrash his wife with
um you you guys desperately needed
marriage counseling a long time ago
long time ago
uh long before he calls on this radio
show
and uh we certainly did not tell him to
pack up his stuff and move and it sounds
like he did that you go back and listen
to the call nowhere did we even intimate
that he should do that we did tell him
you guys need marriage counseling and
baby doll you did need marriage counsel
you do need marriage counseling it's
you guys are a hot mess you you you bow
up and just go do whatever the crap you
want to do and go deeply in debt and buy
a van that you shouldn't have against
his wishes which indicates that you guys
are not on the same page and have
serious marriage problems and he's being
a twerp and a control freak and not
coming up with some way to take care of
his pregnant wife and kids and get her
into a car that works well to that end
everybody wants what they want instead
of being instead of serving each other
in this marriage she says to quote him i
don't care if it has a welded
five-gallon bucket for the front seat
you'll drive what i pick or i won't
agree to it because dave says if you
can't agree you go with who says no
that is not that has never come out of
here i mean we don't that's just that's
just completely weaponizing the advice
here
so yeah jessica you have a mess your
husband is a mess you're in a mess and
you did a stupid thing in the middle of
all that and it hurt to have her laundry
aired out you know on national radio
well i don't blame her for that too and
i'll pick on a lady's getting ready to
have a baby in nine days oh my gosh
so uh but the point is guys this is
if you can't get together on what to do
with money it's not a money problem if
you can't get together on what to do
with your car it's not a car problem
that's a marriage problem and it's
usually a selfishness problem
i mean she was selfish because she just
went and did whatever she wanted to do
he was selfish because he's like i'm not
going to agree to anything because i
don't like it and i'm on the road and
i'm going to hold all the power like he
has any power which apparently he didn't
so
uh you know it was just out of control
so the the inverse of this is
hey i love my wife and i understand
she's freaking out i got to figure out
some way to get her in a different car
that is good for our future and going
further in debt is not good for our
future
instead of
i'm going to tell you what to do and
dave ramsey oh my god you twerp and they
they mentioned we didn't ask their
income they make 137 000
yeah and it paid off a bunch of debt
right yeah how much was it it was a lot
uh 50 000 in 15 months they paid off she
says
so um
uh what but you didn't ask what we made
she said well i didn't ask what you made
because that wasn't the question the
question wasn't it's not an it wasn't a
math problem it was my wife bought a car
that we didn't agree to problem
that was the call it wasn't like how
much money you make how much money
doesn't solve you know youtube not
getting along
so you can make 237 000 and still not
you still shouldn't go do that and he
still shouldn't put you in a position
that you felt like that was the only
thing you could do
so you two are being you're hot mess
you're a hot mess and you need to be in
marriage counseling both of you
bad
and so because here's the thing
sharon ramsay goes and does that
i'm gonna have a problem but i'm also
not gonna put her in a position that she
feels like that's her only way and if
she feels like that's her only way then
she's got a serious cinderella syndrome
like she deserves entitled and i'm
arrogant and whatever then we got
another issue going on and we're going
to be sitting down with with a
professional and helping us guide
through our relationship because
apparently we can't guide through it
ourselves and we've done that ten years
you know after we were married about 10
years we about killed each other that
year
and so we you know marriage counselor
saved our lives and our marriage
saved my life because she probably would
have killed me in my sleep but um
but the uh uh i mean you know and so i
can i distinctly remember driving the
crappy
you remember this is how bad it was you
probably seen these on the road they're
still out there the two-tone blue astro
vans oh yeah you remember those yeah
those are really ugly this is like the
minivan of minivans
and it had like a bazillion miles on it
and i fried the transmission out of it
pulling the boat because it wasn't
designed to pull a boat it was a
lightweight little thing
and i put a new transmission in it and
this thing i mean it stunk it had
cheerios like neck deep in it although
it was we raised little babies in it and
dogs and it was a mess
and she was over this fan
and
rightly so it was a piece of crap and we
were starting to make a little money we
finally got a little bit of money and
she's like i want to get a suburban i
want to get an suv like that's 20 000
might as well be that gum 200 000 what
do you mean well you got 20 000 coming
in down there at your company our
company you keep telling me it's mine i
want some of the money out there by suv
i'm like yeah but that twenty thousand
dollars we can use to invest in this
thing we're working on and it's gonna
make us a hundred thousand if we buy
this car for twenty thousand and we went
back and forth and went
and we just we kept arguing but finally
i had this moment where i went you know
what it's not an either or it's a win
and i said so okay we're gonna we need
to do the investment at the company and
we need to buy the car
and which one which one we do first
which one we do first is the only thing
that mattered and so we just put her
first she won
there we go and you know what when she
won i won boom isn't that interesting
here's the takeaway from this story dave
they've got a child on the way and right
now they're both being children we need
less children in this family
how's that
now you'll get another email george uh
oh yeah
you changed her brand
[Laughter]
this is the ramsey chef
michelle is with us in scranton
pennsylvania hi michelle how are you
dave i'm great how are you thank you for
taking my call sure what's up very
exciting
um
my husband and i are on our baby set too
it's been amazing and to encourage
people out there
if you're starting this journey at 58
it's not too late
and
they can change your life so
and the second most important part is
that my husband wants to know what you
think for
investing and
would you advise sort of to hedge
against inflation
um buying like some gold coins as part
of your emergency fund
okay
um
no
and i wouldn't suggest you buy stock in
home depot either
or apple
or exxon
why
because the price is too volatile to use
as an emergency fund the purpose of the
emergency fund is insurance
not investment
it's there for the rainy day
the umbrella is there for rain only
it is not there to fight off bears
it's just for rain
that makes sense
yes indeed um
so
as so let's say we have the emergency
fund in cash that's all you need needed
with an extra you can put it in the bank
in a savings account if you want
and michelle i'll go
and i would go a step further too
because you're wondering you said my
husband wanting to know about investing
and then specifically in gold but
nowhere in the baby steps do we
recommend people buy gold period so any
other single stocks either like he was
saying
but when it comes to investing in that
time still
not suggests investing in commodities or
anything like that so in the market yes
through good gross dog mutual funds or
in a retirement
vehicle like a
roth ira 401k 403 b but in general our
piece of advice when it comes to
investing is to stay away from gold so
let me kind of talk you through
something too that's interesting so what
this tells me by the way and the way you
asked the question was that your
husband's been reading crap on the
internet
okay
on gold sites
because a he should i buy this you said
as a hedge against inflation
okay now let's talk about how that works
here's the way you've heard of a hedge
fund
right
now a hedge against something
goes with the thing
so the thing doesn't destroy you
meaning that if you want to do a hedge
against inflation you would have to buy
things
that are incorporated in inflation
inflation is the price of bread going up
the price of oil going up the price of
housing going up the price of
electricity going up uh the price of
living going up
gold is not one of those things it does
not follow
inflation
there is no correlation between the
price of gold and inflation zero
there's no correlation between the stock
market going up the stock market going
down in gold zero there is some loose
correlations that really what gold
prices correlate to is fear or greed
when the marketplace deems that the
world's falling apart oh god
and all the conspiracy theorists come
out then the price of gold is going to
go up
but that's what drives the price of gold
up not anything else and so if you
really want to hedge against inflation
you buy real estate you would buy stock
in exxon you would buy stock in wheat
farms you would buy stock in things that
go up in cost when inflation goes up
when the price of things goes up the
things you'd buy stock in general motors
because the price of a car is going to
go up you buy stock in bridgestone
because the price of tires are going to
go up that's a hedge
against inflation gold coins are not
the only place anybody says stuff like
that is on their stupid but gold coin
websites
that's the only place that comes up
that's how i know where he's getting the
information because it's technically the
wrong definition does that make sense
yes but so when gold is going up in
price that's inflation
right that's inflation does gold hold
its value no not necessarily you go back
and pull the goal you can just go online
and pull up gold prices over 50 years
and number one you're going to see about
a 5 rate of return it's got a sucky rate
of return
and it's a freaking roller coaster at
six flags to get there
it's way up and way down just to get to
an a boring average
that's why i don't play in it because
it's too freaking volatile
it's too crazy to ride and i don't find
any millionaires that say i got rich
buying gold coins none i found a lot of
people that got poorer buying gold coins
but i don't find any millionaires in our
millionaire study that says i got rich
buying gold coins so this is where it
comes from yeah and there but there is a
level because i just had a conversation
with a friend about this recently
there's like this level of security
feeling like yeah but gold feels safe
gold it feels like i don't know because
you can actually tangibly touch it and
see it whatever the case may be there's
this element of like oh yeah we're gonna
buy gold because it just feels it feels
safer that's what they were saying and
here's what here's the weird part of
that is it's not when when is it safe
when do you use gold coins
when you use a bar of gold to buy
something
never
okay
i mean go back to
a complete collapse of government
and anarchy in the streets
you know what happens then the first
type of economy that rises up is a
barter-based economy
so when katrina hits new orleans and
wipes the freaking place off the map
because all the levees broke and the
whole place is laying down on the floor
crying
no one ran around with gold bars buying
stuff
but a can of gasoline some brand new
blue jeans some work gloves some bullets
you could trade that for anything for
about six weeks down there
right now you can trade two befores for
just about anything in america
okay with the price of lumber yeah but
nobody's walking around with gold dust
in their pockets this is not the wild
wild west we have a medium of exchange
primarily electronic but also these
little green paper
paper things with president's faces on
them that is our medium of exchange so
this anomaly this weird thing all gold
is safe everything goes to gold when all
the when all hell breaks loose the world
falls apart no it doesn't
i mean you walk through baghdad after
they kill saddam hussein
nobody's walking around the streets
there
with little gold bars doing stuff
immediately comes up with the next
dictator's face on a piece of paper and
this becomes your currency following a
barter black market barter economy which
is what follows anarchy so you go from
anarchy to stabilization and there's
always a currency that pops up following
with the next government i mean
when the civil war broke out the south
they didn't run around with gold bars
they printed up southern money which
became worth nothing
once they were defeated right we were
defeated i was here i wasn't here but
i'd live here but anyway but probably
than that old but anyway but the you
know i mean same thing i got these
little pictures of saddam hussein on
paper money that this guy in special
forces brought me back and three bullets
from an ar right when he was on a thing
there and you know what that paper
money's worth nothing
because the people that supported it are
worth nothing it's gone but there was
never any gold backing any of it up but
so why does fear drive it because you
see i mean like the joke is i feel like
on cable news networks it's always gold
commercial you know commercials
selling gold
and that's
it's on this false premise that if
everything goes to hell in a hand basket
you're safe then you're gonna be okay if
you've got a gold bar in your safe yeah
well that's so much crap it's
unbelievable it just doesn't work that
way
you know you cannot find a failed
economy
consequently a failed government that
has completely collapsed where gold pops
up as the standard
it just doesn't not in the last 300
years
500 years you find me one time in
history you can study it you can't you
know nazi germany hitler takes over is
on a failed economy by the way that's
what put hitler in place okay and uh
they had hyper inflation her question
was about inflation hyperinflation we'll
borrow a load of money to buy a dadgum
loaf of bread so hitler comes in to save
the day he's gonna fix everything with a
stimulus check you know so uh
and goes into power that's what happened
and but they never once went to a gold
standard
today's question comes from john in
california
john writes my wife and i are
approaching 60 and have been married for
30 years she's had a gambling problem
since we got married and it's getting
progressively worse she keeps promising
to quit but every month spends thousands
of dollars on her hobby
hobby i'm just gonna underline that mark
mark that number yeah yeah all right she
has a job but never uses her income
toward our family expenses to add to the
mess we had a daughter that i believe to
be mine until she had a dna test that
showed we are not related so in a
nutshell our marriage is a long-term
sham at this point i have zero interest
in finding a different wife so i see two
possible paths i'll go ahead and mark
that one
we can either divorce and split our net
worth
with me possibly getting strapped with
alimony payments for the rest of my life
or i can put up with her nonsense of
slowly bleeding down our savings and
investments
from a practical point of view it may be
quote unquote cheaper to keep her
but i'd still have to deal with a mental
mess what would you do in my situation
john you're a freaking tragedy wow it's
like a country song it's like two
country songs
and you know i love how you just
completely painted yourself into the
corner and there's only two possible
scenarios out of this and both of them
you die exactly i mean it's likely i'm
gonna starve to death or or have a
psychotic break i'm gonna i'm gonna
absolutely lose my mind or we're gonna
be cheaper to keep her and i'm gonna
tolerate you are making an excuse for
tolerating this all these years because
you hadn't manned up and dealt with the
problems but in the last 30 freaking
years
every home is built with a door on it
john
every home
and if somebody's lying to you about the
whether you're kid they're stealing good
grief
yeah you've got to deal with this asap
and
you're gonna get me all fired up dude
you need to you need to answer the
question here's the question number one
a gambling problem is an addiction not a
hobby stop painting it with this milk
toast wet toast language it's an
addiction you're married to someone who
is struggling with an addiction
number two she's never used she has a
job but she never uses income towards
her family expenses that's your fault
correct number three we have a daughter
that i believe to be mine my nut my
marriage is a long-term sham maybe
but if it is it's because you
participated in this long-term sham okay
i want you to look in the mirror none of
this is new information correct
at this point we have zero interest in
finding a different wife that is
completely irrelevant to the point that
you are worth more than living in a home
where somebody is using you as toilet
paper stop
stop
nonsense
you don't have to be interested in
finding a different wife you can be
interested in preserving your dignity
taking care of your mental and physical
health and helping your wife not deal
with her hobby but possibly get help
because she's ill
should we continue
you can at least you can divorce i'm
never gonna tell somebody to get
divorced but this is a mess you've been
cheated on you have been someone's
liquidating your money you need to go
see an attorney and or a marriage
counselor today that's what i'm saying
here's the thing
people do stupid butt stuff absolutely
that are harmful to other people
and
if it happens to you
once you know shame on her it
happens to you twice happens to you
three times happens to you four times
shame on you happens to you over 30
years since we got married shame on you
for not dealing with it right
and so uh dave ramsey is shaming someone
oh brother you dadgum snowflakes um but
the uh the deal is this it is your fault
that you haven't dealt with this before
now correct and so and you act like
you're somehow stuck you're not stuck no
that's the
the title of my new book own your past
change your future thanks for the
underhand pitch here john from
california you've got to own what is and
what is is you've allowed this you've
allowed yourself to participate in
somebody else's
illness or their addiction or their bad
behavior whatever you want to call it
for 30 years so tell me john on this
what i read is this lady is messed up
and he's almost as messed up as she is
yes so i have
it's hard for me to be hopeful that both
of them can come around
she has ah why would she change her life
her life is fantastic she can do
whatever she wants whatever she wants
whatever she wants with no consequence
and he just looks at her she lives in a
rent-free home
and [ __ ] someone else pays their food
and what it never does anything about it
yeah so here's the deal i mean in other
words he can come in tomorrow and with
the help of a counselor say we're going
to go to a marriage counselor and in
order for me to stay here's what has to
happen
an ultimatum yep okay no more gambling
and your money becomes our money
and um anymore anything that looks or
smells anything like infidelity we're
done right i mean these are
non-negotiables he could come in
tomorrow and then she could say
um oh you're right after 30 years of
doing it this way i'm just going to stop
tomorrow um
probably not right but here's what
here's what what is going to happen
it's not a matter of him saying well
then i guess i have to do this what he
has to do is draw boundaries and then
she gets to choose do i want to be in a
relationship with him yeah and she's
already chosen that by the way that's
for 30 years she has right that she
doesn't that's right
so john you've got to these are two lazy
people they're lazy in that they cannot
deal with their stuff yeah i was
intellectually or they're just so
traumatized yeah whatever the reason is
they're they're not dealing with their
stuff either one of them yeah it's what
i'm seeing so i mean i just it's just
old voice good old boy stuff but anyway
yeah so
that's what i you you are going to if
you asking us what to do we would say
you're going to sit down with a
therapist and uh you're going to say
these are the conditions under which i
stay or you're going to just say i'm
calling it a day click out peace out and
get an attorney and to presuppose that
you're always gonna pay alimony you
probably are after 30 years but that
also is a negotiation
and uh she probably wants free of you
and let me say this not tongue-in-cheek
john you don't know what
going to bed
just going to sleep feels like without
medication
you don't know what it's like laughing
from your guts anymore you don't know
what it's like to be with just a group
of buddies and y'all are having a good
time
you've lost that sense of joy and what i
would tell you is you're approaching 60
you got 30 years left
you can choose from this point forward
to make those 30 years the best 30 years
of your 60 or you can choose to oh this
is this way the point is both paths are
going to be hard choose which kind of
hard you want
you want hard when you slowly drown or
you want hard where you slowly stand
back up you get to pick
yeah
it is way past time to stand up dude
stand up john
all right today's question comes from
jennifer in kansas
my husband is 100 sure that the world
will end soon or martial law will take
effect and money will not hold any value
because of this he will not save he has
business and personal credit card debt
he has zero savings and spends his money
as fast as he makes it he's up to date
on his payments but has no interest in
paying them off so he can start saving i
am currently saving as much as possible
and will have the last of my debt paid
off later this year
i have life insurance in place for all
of us and a 401k he will also be able to
draw my pension at my old job if i
should pass before he does i feel like
i'm the only one preparing for our
future and honestly it's hurtful
i don't know how to get through to him
that even though the world may end in
our lifetime we should still be
responsible with our money and be
prepared
how can i get through to him
dave
how can she get through to him um
well i mean
the extreme way you've explained him
this is not somebody who's merely a
prepper this is not someone who is
merely
feels like that the culture is uh
deteriorating this guy is so sure
that he's so paranoid that that the
whole thing is going to crash down
that he according to you this according
to jennifer that he is doing nothing
responsible
uh he's just living his life today now
or
he's a complete liar
and this is his excuse for being a
freaking child right
and doing whatever he wants to do
either way this guy is
exercising
at a level of mental illness that is
pretty extreme right
this is a paranoia
situation or it's a depression that is
lapsed into i i literally can't think
through
to to tomorrow so i'm just living for
the next five minutes the next 10
minutes yeah and i'll create this
narrative and i will find some websites
that will back up my narrative there's
there's a thousand of these conspiracies
millions of them websites and
you know all you gotta do is watch the
news and it makes them all come true
that's exactly right and uh but they're
not you know so um
let me just tell you that
the world has problems
and uh the world has always had problems
100 of the time and uh but the uh
percentage likelihood of martial law and
of you losing all of your personal
assets coming together in your lifetime
is so small that to believe that 100 to
the point that it affects your behavior
where you do nothing responsible for
your family is called paranoia that is a
mental illness level this is not merely
we have a disagreement about how life
works this is you are your husband is
mentally ill and so let me am i wrong no
and in fact here
dave um what i had a seizure
when um
i had you and i've talked about this i
had mapped out in a very um beautiful
mind kind of way
where this data point led to this one
and this one and i wasn't well and i had
come to figure out that oh the housing
market was going to recollapse and they
were going to have to nationalize i had
created this whole world and so i was
going to cash out this and go do this
and i'll never forget sitting with the
cfo of a 200 million company i sat down
and explained what i was about to do
with my retirement i was gonna cash it
out because money's not gonna and i
remember him gently looking at me and
saying i don't really understand this
please don't do this and i left that
meeting and i thought he didn't see it
he didn't get it and i'm a guy that
barely knows how to work a spreadsheet
right so here's the thing um when
somebody is in this position the data
and facts don't help a lot
but somebody in this position needs to
go get help yeah i had to go sit down
with somebody and say i'm i'm seeing the
world different than everyone around me
who loves me i need some help yeah and
you're right the world's got problems it
does um one of my close friends gave me
a quote that has stuck with me forever
and he said john i got a lot of plans
but i don't have a meteorite plan if a
meteorite hits us i will deal with that
on that day
and the idea that suddenly money's going
to hold no value and tanks are going to
roll on every street
if that happens i'll deal with that on
that day and until then i'm going to be
responsible and care for my wife who
feels like she's drowning over here by
herself and we're going to go from there
yeah he's not going to give in to that
because it's futile right
just futile
yeah there there's yeah he he needs to
need help he needs to see a counselor
yeah he needs help so jennifer no amount
of you sitting down trying to explain
stuff to him how can i get through to
him you can't you cannot you can't
because his brain is not functioning
properly right
if somebody in his life that he is
somebody that he trusts that would sit
down with him and say hey let's go talk
to somebody great if you say hey i'm
going to go talk to someone i'd love you
to join me to be great uh but he needs
to get some help yeah i i by the way he
he doesn't think he needs help so that's
probably gonna be very difficult so but
just to
the point is is that this is not he
isn't
you're not gonna solve this riddle
you don't have the tool set i did have a
friend that came and spoke truth to me
my wife spoke truth to me and i wasn't
this bad um but uh that was helpful it
was two people that i trusted and i said
i'm gonna go talk somebody then yeah
well and i think you might get some
guidance from a a good counselor if you
were seeing one on how to deal with this
situation
because here's what's ultimately going
to happen okay having dealt with couples
in your situation for 30 years
one of two things is going to occur
and there's really not much middle
ground there's not a third thing it's
one of two
he is going to recognize this get some
help and gradually over time get better
and your lives are going to get better
and get more normalized and you're going
to be able to aim at a future and build
a build some wealth and get out of debt
and start living reasonably and you're
going to start taking some incremental
not instantaneous but some incremental
steps in that direction which will give
you hope
if that does not occur
100 of the time
at some point you are going to boil over
a switch is going to flip
and you're gonna be done
and there's there's going to be no
talking you back
because when ladies in particular
are done
after holding their breath for a decade
or for
three years or for whatever when they're
done
you can't switch them back on you can't
switch them back into love mode it's
you're in resentment and that's actually
it's over that's right it's over and uh
because they they've
they reached that i've had it moment and
it's there they really have had it and
they're really gone and so don't let
that happen to you
uh it's going to happen to you if you
don't control the process now you can
control the process and you say okay i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna give him this
much time i'm gonna try these five
things to encourage him at that point
i'm gonna call this because this
relation i can't be married to a crazy
person
and he is mentally ill darling he's
mentally ill we just diagnosed it um
dave
some of this feels like a
self-fulfilling prophecy to me
that if you get enough people saying
well
money's going to be of no value so let's
just blow it all and run up all of our
debts and go but
that that's the quickest way for money
to have some serious problems right is
that fair i don't know enough about
monetary policy that it just feels like
you're we're starting to see a what
rabbi lapin says he says money is not
actual it's spiritual
so when i give you a hundred dollar bill
the actual paper is not worth a hundred
dollars right it's a spiritual
transaction of trust
and so when i give you a hundred dollar
bill you accept that hundred dollar bill
for a hundred dollars in goods and
services or you get eyes get big and you
say thank you or whatever it is because
you trust that you can take that and do
something with it
and so what you're saying is it's a
valid point that if enough people lose
that trust
then the money is destroyed
elizabeth starts this hour in san
antonio hi elizabeth how are you
hi i'm doing great
um
so what's going on and i actually wish i
was calling to say to do my debt-free
stream i've been wanting to do that for
a long time
uh we are debt-free the house has paid
off the cars are paid off everything
um i am working full-time and a student
also and then
in about a year i'll go full-time
where i won't work also for nursing um
and my husband he works full-time he's
phd scientist
and then we have a 18 year old son who
has moved out and started a business he
didn't want to go to college
how can we help today
okay just wanted to lay the foundation
so
we've got everything paid off and my
husband wants to buy an all-electric
vehicle and we were going to
save up for it to pay cash
and currently we have two prius that are
um not the plug-in kind
and
suddenly now today he wants to go
purchase it he feels like there's a
sudden need that we need to do it now
because of everything that's going on in
the world and that
this is the time not wait so we're also
cash flow in my school and so we do have
sorry what's going on in the world that
demands that you get a plug-in vehicle
today i missed
i didn't watch the news this morning
so he feels like
we um
like
potentially in the future we're gonna
have no idea
yeah yeah and that we would be better
off getting it now that
are you telling me the guy has a phd and
he truly believes there's going to be no
gasoline
no not no gas no just okay so we're both
very frugal and we um
so you know what is going on in the
world
that demands that you buy an electric
vehicle you said hey with all that's
going on in the world what the crap does
that mean
well that the demand for electric
vehicles is going up and that they are
harder and harder to get and there's a
long wait list for you know all the ones
that are on the market right now
um and in other words i want an electric
vehicle
and i don't want to wait and i don't
want to wait and so i'm just now i'm
making up crap to worry about okay so
what's your household income
so our household income is about 155.
he makes 113 i make about 43. okay and
what are you going to what are you
buying what kind of a car is he wanting
like a tesla
um so
we're between the dw uh id4
the bolt was just recalled on friday so
we can't get that one which was much
less expensive and then our only other
option really is the tesla
okay
so let me help you with the math to
start with
you can drive that freaking tesla to the
moon and back
and mathematically you will never
justify
how much more you've spent on the tesla
than you're paying off than you than the
value of your prius
you know how much time it's going to
take you to recoup 45
dollars in electric and gas savings
the rest of your freaking life
okay so let me just tell you
mathematically this is asinine that
we're using the idea that we're saving
money because we're frugal to get an
electric car
now if you want to go get a tesla
fine go get you a tesla but pay cash for
it
but you don't you don't say oh
everything that's going on in the world
and we're frugal people because both of
those things are stupid but statements
because they don't have anything to do
with reality okay that you know
everything that's going on in the world
they're making teslas you can get a
tesla i mean it's not
you know and they're not going to be
like not able to get one and if you're
not able to get one like a delorean
that means you didn't want one because
they went broke okay
and elon didn't make it you know but um
but the uh but if you get one which is
fine i got several friends at the bottom
um i prefer a motor but that's okay get
you one it gets you a battery it's okay
and so but but the point is you guys
make enough money to pay cash for a
sixty thousand dollar car
here's what i think in cash i knew where
you buy it
when when our brains go to fight or
flight when we're scared
it actually has a cool bypass mechanism
in your brain that turns off your
critical thinking
part of your of your brain
because you it didn't want you sitting
at the front of a cave wondering is that
a nice tiger or is that a fluffy one a
petting tiger it just wanted you to run
or to grab a stick and go to war because
if if it happened to be a mean tiger and
you thought it was a nice one you were
going to be dead right and so it's a
cool little feature our brains have
where it trades it trades speed for
accuracy close enough
and it sounds like you've got a husband
who loves you loves your kids and is
consuming
24 7 365 news
and he's worked himself up in a panic
and he's sitting there at home and at
home and at home and what i need to do i
need to do something to do something and
he can go down a rabbit hole that's
going to shoot him out one media
slide that's going to tell him we're
going to be at oil it's going to be 111
a gallon it's going to be this and that
and then he's comes up with a solution
that makes no mathematical sense
rational sense climate it makes no sense
but it feels like it's the right thing
to do
and what i need that guy to do is to
close the devices
get connected to a human being
go sit down and tell somebody i'm
terrified and i'm about to make a wild
decision that doesn't make any
mathematical sense doesn't make any
rational sense
that i'm i'm not i'm not okay it's
contrary to my goals it's it's not where
i want to be the goals the goals of this
family have been to become and be debt
free and out of left field mr phd dumps
into the middle and goes ah
we gotta finance a tesla i'm gonna buy a
depreciation computer and everything
that's going on in the world
you're right his brain is completely
shut down so let's go to the devoid of
critical let's go to the end result the
end thing here let's say there we do run
out of gas dave or the gas becomes 100
i'm just having fun for a second it's
not fun and it does
having an electric car will be the your
neighbors will line up in your driveway
to shoot you if you're the only electric
car
so the world that you are predicting
that you're going to solve for is not
going to look like the world you have
now plus you have electric car so it's
okay that when i panicked i bought
bullets
i said i'm not saying that's okay
i'm saying that
yeah whatever yes way to go dave so what
i'm saying is when you solve for chaos
you're solving an improbable math
problem right so what does that mean it
means you're not okay yeah your husband
spun out and he needs to put the
computer down put the debit card down
and go sit down and talk to somebody
he's not okay
if you enjoyed this episode click here
to watch the next one you're going to
hear the biggest financial mistakes our
callers have ever made